hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is a 6.3 inch
phone
it's a 6.3 inch phone it's a bit of a
test from samsung to see how big of a
device you and i are willing to keep
buying we bought the 5-inch galaxy s4 we
bought the 5.5 inch galaxy note 2 how
big are we willing to go with this i'm
going to try to review this entire
device without saying that's what she
said once it's going to be a bit of a
challenge but without any further ado
let's take a closer look at the samsung
galaxy mega so this is the mega 6.3 and
obviously yes it is gigantic as you can
see next to the galaxy s4 and it's
really easy to say it's too big even too
big for a pocket but it does fit in my
pockets just fine and even in purses
quite easily obviously but yeah there's
no other way to put it this is the
biggest smartphone out there right now
and it even makes the galaxy note 2 feel
a bit small and while a lot of people
will immediately dismiss this phone as
being way too big there is a select
group of people out there looking for
something like this a device that's
bigger than your typical smartphone but
pocketable unlike the smallest of
tablets so this can take the place of
both in your life the smartphone and the
tablet and this galaxy mega actually
does a pretty good job of that for my
experience now from a samsung point of
view this device is basically an
experiment they have that kind of money
where they can put out some crazy new
form factors and if people like it and
buy it they'll keep doing it if not they
won't they took a pretty big leap with
the galaxy note and the galaxy note 2
and people ate that up so they're going
even bigger now with a 5.9 inch and a
6.3 inch galaxy mega variant with the
same looks as a galaxy s4 it's kind of
like a vote with your wallet thing at
this point if people like it and buy it
samsung will see that and we'll see more
of this trend anyway because this is
such an experiment the galaxy mega does
not have flagship specs because it's not
a flagship it has android 4.2.2 inside
but it's running a quad-core snapdragon
400 cpu at a 1.7 gigahertz clock speed
and it scores a little more than half of
what the galaxy s4 with the snapdragon
600 does on quadrant but luckily it
doesn't need more than a whole ton of
power because while this display is
massively huge it is not 1080p this is a
1280x720 display so it doesn't need
nearly as much power to push around way
less pixels so you sacrifice a bit of
pixel density for a much better
performance on the chip but the display
is still great actually colors as you
would expect with the samsung amoled
display are very vibrant and viewing
angles and brightness are still
top-notch very good and that adds to the
media consumption experience on this
tablet
phone hybrid it's much more fun to watch
youtube videos on this than anything
else in samsung's galaxy lineup and
speaking of that galaxy lineup the mega
is very similar to the galaxy s4 inside
and out it has a removable back to
reveal a small speaker at the bottom but
it is pretty loud and there's also a
micro sd card slot up top for expandable
storage next to that 8 megapixel camera
and of course that brings us to one of
the biggest advantages to carrying a
mammoth of a phone like this
battery life this is the biggest battery
in any phone 3 200 milliamp hours and it
can go for a long time on a battery it's
almost impossible to kill this thing in
a day even with heavy use and there are
some other advantages to having such a
ridiculously sasquatch gargantuan phone
one is that you get more information on
the screen you just get more it might
not be 1080p so it's not the sharpest
thing in the world unfortunately so text
could use a little bit of improvement
but you can see so much in every app on
the mega each and every app just looks
bigger than it usually does on any other
phone and the entire user interface
scales and looks just mega sized all of
it looks huge and it doesn't even feel
that tall it feels more really wide apps
don't stretch anymore obviously to take
up the extra room but they instead sit
in the middle of the display with tons
of space on either side it's quite nice
actually this would be a great phone for
someone with not very good eyesight or
for someone with really large hands or
large fingers or someone who wears big
gloves all the time who knows and just
of course if you feel like using this
with one hand samsung added some of the
single-handed features that it used in
the galaxy note 2 just in case you feel
the need to use this device with one
hand for some of the apps and yet
another advantage of the huge display is
the camera here it feels like taking
pictures with a tablet but not really
but the fact of the matter is with this
display it's so big that it kind of
feels like you're looking through a
window at what you want to take a
picture or video of and with the really
solid 8 megapixel sensor in here likely
the same optics as the galaxy s3 i've
never had an easier time composing shots
and taking them on any other phone now i
also do want to say one of the biggest
and most underrated advantages to having
a larger screen on a phone is having a
larger keyboard and believe me when i
say the on-screen typing experience on
the galaxy make 6.3 is oh so good with
any keyboard whether it's google's or
samsung's or third parties the fact that
you have so much space for your fingers
to move around and hit them keys oh man
it's a great time great time texting or
messaging on this thing so basically in
summary the galaxy mega is a giant phone
that enhances all the things that are
good about having a great huge display
all the media all the games and video
watching it's all great thanks to the
screen and since they took the galaxy s4
design but the galaxy s3 specs it's a
mid-range performer and definitely an
interesting experiment from samsung it's
gonna fall in the same category as the
galaxy note 2 where people will stop you
in public and ask you about your phone
it's also in the same category where it
takes a little bit of time to get used
to the size but once you get used to the
mega it can be an all-in-one device that
replaces your tablet and your phone and
really does give you the best of both
worlds with an all-day battery life that
fits in your pocket and then of course
lastly what a lot of people ask me when
they want to see what this phone is like
they want to know what it looks like
held up to your ear when making a phone
call because people still make those
not bad i mean it's not quite as
ridiculous as a tablet but it's probably
bigger than any other phone you've ever
used either way that's been it it's the
samsung galaxy mega i would say there's
a lot to like about this phone
especially like we said the advantages
of having such a big battery and such a
big phone overall all those advantages
are still there but i would still say
that i prefer a 1080p display i wouldn't
recommend buying this phone only because
this is the best look we're going to get
at the samsung galaxy note 3 and when
that phone does come out it's going to
have flagship specs it's going to have
top of the line numbers top of the line
internals and externals and display and
that's going to make this phone look a
little bit dull but if you don't have
the budget for the galaxy note 3 this is
a great alternative and if you're
looking for a big phone that lasts just
all day on battery and then some
galaxy mega is uh it's a place to look
it's a samsung experiment and i think
it's gonna sell interestingly either way
thanks for watching this quick review
video if you enjoyed it definitely feel
free to give a thumbs up below and
without any further ado i'll sign off
here now and i will talk to you guys in
the next one
you